alright as you saw I'm chairman shift
there say they're going to take a break
now because there are they're still
legislating the needs to go on there's
votes that need to happen so the so the
guests are now leaving the the witnesses
pardon me so that is Dave Holmes who is
a foreign service officer a career
diplomat also that is dr. Fiona Holmes
who is a Russia expert and they make
pretty powerful statements and have been
questioned as you saw by the the
Democrats they will follow up with
questioning by the Republicans when they
come back let's just give you a taste of
what Dave Holmes said I'm he he talked
about realizing that there was basically
a different type of policy that was
happening with Ukraine let's go ahead
and listen to what he had to say
beginning in March 2019 the situation at
the Embassy and in Ukraine changed
dramatically
specifically the three priorities of
security economy and justice and our
support for Ukrainian democratic
resistance to Russian aggression became
overshadowed by a political agenda
promoted by former New York New York
City Mayor Rudy Giuliani
and a cadre of officials operating with
the direct channel to the White House
okay we'll be speaking to our White
House correspondent Kimberly how could
in a moment first let's get to Heidi Joe
Castro who is outside the chambers where
Heidi I think the top line and I think
you would probably agree is dr. Fiona
Hill basically with a warning to the
committee about what Russia's goals have
been about how they are still being
effective and what their goals are which
is to D legitimize the US presidency
that's that's what she said and and also
testimony from for mr. Holmes about
basically how the official policy of the
US towards Ukraine had basically been
hijacked for lack of a better word what
else did you hear
that's right and Hill doctor Hill really
put this in the big-picture context of
all of this and warning as you said it's
a great description of how she phrased
this she said specifically to the
committee members she said Russia is
watching and the things being discussed
in these hearings the ways the partisan
ways that these questions are being
phrased in particular trying to
highlight these debunked conspiracy
theories that Ukraine somehow was
involved in election meddling in 2016
she said that plays right into Russia's
hand and that what's happening now is
her worst fear that Russia had so this
just scored within the two political
parties in the US and that Russia may be
using what state said now as ammunition
into further election meddling in the
year 2020 but that as far as the merits
of this case the Democrats are trying to
build for the possible impeachment of
President Trump it is the David Holmes
the Kiev embassy staffer that's really
delivering the bigger news on that front
because he was a witness to a phone call
between the u.s. ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sunland and president Trump that
occurred on July 26 this is the day
after Trump had spoken with the
president of Ukraine on the phone
explicitly asking for investigations
into Joe Biden and just let me set the
scene for this overheard call so the day
after Trump got off the phone with
szalinski Holmes was meeting with
szalinski as a follow-up he said that
the president of Ukraine said three
times that Trump had brought up
sensitive information on this call
sensitive issues were his words that
which he later understood meant these
investigations into Biden and then
afterwards as the US officials were
sitting down for a lunch he was
surprised home says because Sunland the
ambassador to the EU pulled out his
phone
in the middle of lunch on a patio
restaurant in Kiev he dialed the number
for the President of the United States
and this is what home said he overheard
well ambassador Cylons phone was not on
speakerphone I could hear the
president's voice through the earpiece
of the phone
the president's voice was loud and
recognizable an ambassador Soglin held
the phone away from his ear for a period
of time presumably because of the loud
volume
I heard ambassador Stalin greet the
president and explained he was calling
from keeve I heard president Trump then
clarified that ambassador Soglin was in
Ukraine ambassador Stalin replied yes he
was in Ukraine and went on to state the
president Solinsky quote loves her ass I
then heard president Trump ask so he's
going to do the investigation
ambassador songline replied that he's
going to do it adding that President
Solinsky will do anything you ask him to
do and Holmes put all of this into
perspective as well he said that
beginning in early March he felt that
his work on behalf of US policy toward
Ukraine was being overshadowed by this
shadow campaign led by the president's
private attorney Rudy Giuliani Holmes
also testified that he had a clear
understanding that a visit for szalinski
an oval office meeting with Trump was
conditioned on Ukraine delivery
investigations into Biden and then
further he said that it was also his
clear impression that the security aid
400 million dollars from the u.s. to
help Ukraine defend itself against
Russia he said was quote likely intended
by Trump to pressure Ukraine to launch
those investigations which gets right to
the heart of this impeachment inquiry
whether or not President Trump was
withholding that aid for his own
political gain you know Heidi one thing
that the the White House's has
consistently said as have Republican
members of this committee they keep
saying this is all hearsay there's no
one with the first-hand account of
course people that do have first-hand
first-hand accounts rather the White
House has forbidden them to testify but
but David Holmes said that he realized
you know what
do have a first-hand account I I heard
this conversation and it's pretty
powerful what he said I was there that's
right and he said that he had actually
alerted his superiors at the Embassy
immediately after this conversation took
place on the restaurant patio and then
in retrospect as he was watching these
hearings unfold and he heard Republicans
attacking the inquiry saying that all of
his evidence was secondhand that's when
the light bulb went off in his head and
he said well actually I have first-hand
information and he brought that back to
the attention of his boss ambassador
bill Taylor which is what got Holmes
into the hot seat in the first place
bringing him to tell this story in
person and it begs the question just how
much more first-hand information is out
there that investigators are simply
unaware of you know it would could be
these lower-level staffers the have that
information a possible smoking gun that
still Republicans would argue has not
been established to directly implicate
the president and perhaps the bigger
question is as you alluded to Rochelle
is that there are certainly people who
would know definitively what the
president's thinking was on this and
they are the acting chief of staff of
the White House and Ambassador John
Bolton himself and both of those
individuals and of course Rudy Giuliani
I should say so those three individuals
have all not complied with a request to
tell their stories to these
investigators okay Heidi Joe Castro live
at Capitol Hill Heidi we'll come back to
you right now we're gonna go to our
White House correspondent Kimberley
halket Kimberly the the testimony so far
from Russia expert dr. Fiona Hill I
think could be described as a really a
stark warning she laid out what she says
the goals of Russia have been what she
says they still are and how this relates
to to Ukraine and to the US presidency
she said that Russia wants to deal ajith
amaizing regardless of who who would
have been the prize
and that they want to paint Ukraine in a
bad in a bad light because the goal is
to drive a wedge between the US and its
allies it it seems that Russia at least
from what we can see has been effective
in that regard how do you think that
this will be received by by the White
House well I think the headline here
from dr. Fiona Hills testimony is not
only sort of her expertise but the swipe
that she took at the president she was
very clear in denouncing what she says
is a false narrative that she believes
has been perpetuated by President Trump
and also by some members of the
committee namely the Republicans she in
fact at one point which was particularly
powerful spoke to Republican members of
the House Intelligence Committee
accusing them of promoting politically
driven falsehoods I believe is the
phrase she used for domestic political
purposes it s is what she's saying is
that they have been perpetuating a sort
of an argument that has been put forward
by what she says are Russian security
services that Ukraine in fact meddled in
the 2016 US election when the United
States from multiple security services
and multiple tiers of the US government
has conclusively proven that it was
Russia that meddled in the 2016 US
election she goes even further to really
issue a very stark warning that it is
dangerous to perpetuate this narrative
because she says that Russia is prepared
to act again in 2020
right now Russia's security services and
their proxies have geared up to repeat
their interference in the 2020 election
we are running out of time to stop them
in the course of this investigation I
would ask that you please not promote
politically driven falsehoods that so
clearly advance Russian interests
so what really she's saying here and
she's taking a direct swipe at President
Trump is that for domestic political
purposes you have to remember with the
background of all of this Rochelle was
when the president was being
investigated for potential collusion
between his campaign in 2016 and Russia
so he would very much have an interest
in perpetuating along with Republican
allies the notion that perhaps it was
Ukraine that was actually involved so
this is somebody with expertise at the
highest levels of the US government
countering the president directly and
she also said she also said Kimberly
that President Trump did dismiss the the
expert advice that he got that made it
clear that Russia was responsible for
meddling in in the u.s. election and
Kimberly if we go back to Helsinki
when President Trump was up there at a
podium with Vladimir Putin he has said
publicly how he has disparage the
intelligence community publicly and it
seems that what dr. Fiona Hill is saying
is is this is dangerous and it's still
happening yeah and there's no question
that that is something that already the
United States seems underprepared for
moving forward to the 2020 US elections
but sort of looking on the spotlight of
today and the president's actions as we
saw last week as we've seen even in the
last few hours this is a president that
defends himself directly in real time
and we saw the president in advance of
these hearings and even during these
hearings once again tweeting repeatedly
in his defense one of the latest tweets
he in fact tried to discredit some of
the testimony coming from the foreign
service officer David Holmes trying to
say that he doesn't have these types of
conversations that have been
characterized as being very loud we
heard from not only the ambassador
sunland the day previously but also
today about these telephone calls the
president injecting himself into the
testimony here we also had him
characterizing the Democrats as human
scum calling these hearings the most
fare in American history never in my
wildest dreams did I think I would be
associated with the ugly word
impeachment but that is exactly what is
happening right now these are
impeachment inquiry investigations soon
there will be a vote in the House of
Representatives then later a trial in
the US Senate that is exactly what's
going on but we see this president
continuing to fight back even in the
face of very damning testimony ok can
really help get from the White House
Kimberly we'll get back to you let's
talk a little bit more about the the
testimony of a David Holmes the foreign
service officer who actually worked at
the Embassy in Ukraine he testified
about when it became clear to him that
this so called three amigos of course
led by ambassador Saul and the
ambassador to the EU he testified
yesterday he was also in charge of
Ukraine policy which seemed to be
something that through mr. homn said
here's the moment he realized that that
they were running Ukraine policy well
ambassador Stalin's mandate as
ambassador as the accredited ambassador
to the European Union did not cover
individual member states let alone
non-member countries like Ukraine he
made clear that he had direct and
frequent access to President Trump and
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney and
portrayed himself as the conduit to the
President and mr. Mulvaney for this
group secretary Perry ambassador Sandlin
and Ambassador Volcker later styled
themselves the three amigos and made
clear they would take the lead on
coordinating our policy and engagement
with his elinsky administration Robinson
Woodard burns his assistant professor of
the department a political science at
Howard University he is in Washington DC
thank you very much for your time so
what mr. Holmes described there this
basically shadow US policy in regards to
Ukraine is that normal that is not
normal
there are a few points mr. Holmes made
that suggested that this is unusual one
is what we just heard that Gordon
Sandlin was acting outside of his normal
jurisdiction effectively taking more
interest in Ukraine than a normal
ambassador to the European Union would
another point we see is
so called three amigos at the center of
which was mr. Soglin but also
secretaries Harry acting in ways to
advance presidents Trump's personal
interests mr. Holmes has suggested
rather than consistent u.s. foreign
policy interests towards Ukraine that
mr. Holmes and the American delegation
had been advancing prior to mr. song
ones involvement and in fact let me get
this here mr. Holmes described official
US policy in regards to Ukraine to be
promoting peace economic growth and
anti-corruption so that's what he and
the the other staff were working towards
and at one point chairman Schiff trying
to juxtapose that the fact that on the
surface the u.s. is supposed to be
fighting anti-corruption but that seemed
to be at odds with Rudy Giuliani
promoting the the personal interest of
the president how is that undermine
policy what mr. Holmes into some degree
dr. hill pointed out is that Rudy
Giuliani was urging Ukrainians to
investigate hunter Biden Joe Biden's son
which both mr. Holmes and dr. hill
suggested was done for political reasons
this was seen as sort of de railing
American foreign policy making
Ambassador Jovanovic was removed it
seems at the behest of mr. Giuliani in
part because she was seen as an obstacle
to the investigation that Giuliani and
sanglant wanted one thing that came out
of someone's testimony yesterday that's
particularly damning is suggesting that
a number of White House staffers knew
about this sort of shadow foreign policy
effort and were involved in it including
acting chief of staff Mulvaney but also
Secretary of State Pompeo and the vice
president and the President himself
that's pretty damning it's serious okay
so what has been testified what the
testimony that has come out is that
there was this quid pro quo multiple
witnesses have said this that that
president Solinsky would not get a
meeting at the White House with
President Trump and
would not be released if he did not make
an announcement not necessarily actually
make an investigation but make an
announcement about an investigation into
the company buries m'a and the Biden's
and and let's let's break that down a
little bit so this aide had actually
been approved by Congress even having
said that a president has a lot of
latitude when it comes to foreign policy
was he really with it was he within his
rights to hold aid that had already been
approved so the president has wide
foreign policy Authority and for a long
time has the concern is why the
president would withhold this and it's
again that justification that makes all
the difference 391 million dollars for
javelin anti-tank missiles was promised
by Congress to Ukraine and what these
hearings are pointing out is that this
shadow foreign policy then took that
promised aid and made it contingent on a
public announcement by evidently
ukrainian president Solinsky that there
would be an investigation into hunter
biden Joe Biden's son that's the part
that's a bit unorthodox and I was struck
by something that Russia expert dr.
Fiona Hill said she said the the impact
of the successful 2016 Russian campaign
remains evident today she's speaking of
the Russian campaign the their goal to
interfere in the u.s. election she says
our nation is being torn apart truth is
questioned our highly professional and
expert career foreign service is being
undermine is is what she's saying on
display right now one thing that's come
out of this is that there are a series
of career foreign service officers mr.
Holmes today dr. hill and also people
like lieutenant colonel vendôme and
dedicated members of the armed services
and intelligence operations that are
pretty unnerved by the Trump
administration's
evident attempt to run a shadow foreign
policy in opposition to sort of American
foreign policy goals so that's one thing
that came out another thing that dr.
hill pointed out he
that this effort by Donald Trump
essentially to adopt a Russian initiated
and now discredited conspiracy theory of
Ukrainian intervention in the 2016
election continues to undermine foreign
policy again
Trump's sort of repetition of these
debunked Russian claims dr. hill is
worried is undermining not only American
foreign policy towards Ukraine but also
domestically the security of American
elections and domestic policy generally
that's pretty weighty stuff I mean we're
describing the u.s. president basically
using Russian talking points how
concerning is that dr. hill said
something to that effect she wanted to
sort of dispel any partisan ideas that
Trump is say a Russian puppet or giving
direct Russian talking points what she
said instead is that while Trump had
sort of adopted these theories it's not
clear that he is operating on behalf of
Russian foreign policy she doesn't want
to make those kinds of allegations but
merely to point out that in sort of
derailing u.s. foreign policy by chasing
these theories peddled by Russia he is
sort of affected foreign policy in a
negative way so it's not quite that
she's saying he's not necessarily saying
that he's doing it because they are
telling him to but the effect is the
same he's still repeating things that
have been debunked by his own
intelligence community he is doing that
and that has been the consistent message
and also essentially resisting findings
from by part artist by partisan findings
from Senate Intelligence and from the
House Democratic minority of the
Intelligence Committee and in that dr.
hill has pointed out he is undermining
us essentially intelligence and
congressional findings yes okay Robinson
woodruf burn time stay close we'll get
back to you